The information is power, and we don't want people
to be powerless.
And that is what I see with people dealing
with any kind of disease.
But you know, cancer is just one that is highlighted right now
is that if you don't take charge of your own health
and if you don't become the driver of your own health
you just kind of do like a somebody that goes to the car
mechanic and just drop off your car and then pick it up
after the weekend, you know, we can't do that with our bodies.
You know, we shouldn't just kind of here take my body
and fix it, we need to be engaged and involved
in our own healing process and with that education
and knowledge like your podcast that you're doing
becomes so important so that we can then be involved
and empower ourselves and empower our bodies,
you know, that God-given energy that we have
and use that to truly heal and behold individuals.
Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters.
Welcome to another episode of Cutters, clinic live today.
We interviewed special guest who's become a friend of mine,
Dr. Michael Carfelt.
He is running the Carfelt clinic on the west coast
far away from where we are.
And we're going to talk more about what he does in his clinic
and what he can bring to the table.
We always believe that there's a lot of pieces to the puzzle
when you're trying to heal and you need to utilize
every piece that you can or wherever you feel like God is leading you.
So I try to introduce you to great practitioners,
people that I think are good at great pieces to the puzzle.
So Dr. Michael, how are you today?
I'm doing good.
Thank you so much for having me, Dr. Conor.
This is going to be great.
I'm excited.
Yes.
So give us a little more of a rundown of your clinic
where you're located, how people could contact you.
And then let's get into some things that we want to chat about.
Yeah, my clinic is pretty unique.
I mean, one of the things that we offer
is the photodynamic therapy.
And I know we talk a little bit about that before.
But the key with photodynamic therapy in regards
to cancer specifically is to be able to target the cancer directly
without harming healthy cells.
And you can use an combination of what's
called a photosensitizer to do that.
And so the trick is to get a photosensitizer
that tends to accumulate in the tumor.
And then we can then use a laser.
So we do intravenous, we do interstitial
where you bring needles down to the tumor.
And in order to be able to oxidize the tumor.
So that is the key component of why people
fly from a little bit all over the place
to do the therapies I do.
And then we do a bunch of other things as well
because cancer, as you know, it's a one, it's a complex disease.
So you need to address it on so many different levels.
You can't just do kind of one hit wonder
and think that that's going to take care of it.
You need to kind of lean on it from all these different angles.
And that's what I pride myself in doing here
at the Carful Center because we offer just so many different therapies
to kind of lean on cancer, both spiritually, emotionally, physically,
and so we can do a whole body approach
that I know you do with what you're doing.
So now I know we spoke about the photodynamic therapy before,
but that's becoming more of a foundational piece of your clinic.
I had some patients ask me on our Zoom call about that
and what you do.
Is it better for more surface tumors?
Is it still worked for a deep tumor?
Tell us a little bit about that.
Yeah, so photodynamic therapy has been around for a long time,
but the challenge has been to be able to get the photosensitizer
and the light to the side of the tumor, enough of the laser light
to the tumor to have an effect.
So what has been done in the past
because of those challenges has been mostly surface tumors,
like melanomas, any kind of skin cancer, even throat,
they've been able to do that,
but with newer technology that has been brought in,
that we're utilizing here at the center,
we then have the ability then to bring interstitial needles,
optic needles then to the tumor side,
and then surround the tumor then with the laser light
so we can hit it from several angles at the same time,
and then also you can inject then the die around the tumor site
and allow that absorption,
and also it has to do with a type of die that has been used
and that is also something that has evolved quite a bit.
So we brought in a number of things
that we actually get from Germany that have most dies in the past
and a die, people can think of a die.
If you do a, you go and get a PET scan,
they'll use a die in order to be able to get good imaging.
It accumulates in the tumor cells.
So the issue with that is that die then goes out of the system
quite quickly so it doesn't stay in the tumor for a long period of time.
If you take an image the next day,
you wouldn't be able to really see that accumulation within the tumor.
The evolution of die that I'm using
and this good friend of mine works at a university in Germany
that developed this specific one called Nano ICG
that is structured in a way so that over time it accumulates in the tumor cell
and it stays there for longer period of time
which gives us the opportunity to treat that tumor
for longer period of time with the optic therapies.
That becomes the beauty and then obviously you have
the tumors that are in locations like in the lungs.
We don't want to stick a needle into the lung,
but we can then use and very strong laser
then externally as long as there's enough die within that tumor
and then be able to get enough kind of juice
so to say into the tumor even though we're not sticking a needle into it,
to trigger reactive oxygen species.
So you can do that with both laser
and then you can also combine that with ultrasound
because ultrasound also functions like a...
It triggers the creation of reactive oxygen species
and it was called cavitation bubbles within the tumor
to trigger killing of the tumor cells.
So there are technologies and that is a beauty of what we do
and that is quite cutting edge is to utilize these technologies
to be able to treat deeper seeded tumors
versus just the ones that are superficial.
How often do you have to do that procedure
that is it's something you do daily multiple times a day
and then how many minutes is each session?
So what we do, so people tend to come here
and they stay here for a couple of weeks
and so in the beginning of those couple of weeks,
the first couple of days that is when we introduce the photosensitizers
and then we treat that every day.
So that way we treat it with ultrasound,
we treat it with intravenous and external laser every day.
We also use our powerful laser bed with 1800 watts
to really kind of get as much light and juice into that tumor
to cause as much creation of reactive oxygen species
to trigger that cell death.
So yeah, so we want to kind of lean on that tumor as much as possible.
Is the IV therapy that you're doing
is that just an addition to that there's not as a laser IV,
obviously it's that you're doing something
with nutrients IV therapy that you mentioned?
Yeah, so we do nutrients in addition to the intravenous laser therapy
and the beauty with the laser therapy is that you are able
then to treat the blood as it's passing by.
So you're treating the whole and the blood passes by one spot
the body about once every minute.
So in a and we treat for about an hour
which means that you're able to treat the whole blood volume
then for a whole hour and for about 60 times
and in that hour.
And so in your blood, what you have there
is that you have things like circulating tumor cells,
you have cancer stem cells that are there.
And so by treating them the blood
and killing those circulating tumor cells
and cancer stem cells,
you are then as they die,
then the immune system is able to recognize them better
than trigger them an appropriate antibody response
to those specific components.
And the beauty is that you're treating exactly the cancer stem cells
that are in the body at that time
and the circulating tumor cells that are at that time.
So you're actually allowing them the body
to create like the perfect vaccine,
you know, using that very kind of contained system type of treatment
you know, with optic needle in intravene
treating the blood as it's passing by.
And then we combine that with other nutritional substances
you know, that are also putting pressure on the cancer processes.
You know, like we do combination of polyMVA and DCA
and DCA is known to kind of help to shut down
how the cancer cells are able them to get energy.
So you are then starving the cancer
and the cancer is very vulnerable in regards
to its energy because it is not very efficient
and how it creates energy.
So any time you can then put pressure on how it's able to produce energy
it is then going to really suffer
and it's easier than to trigger oxidation.
They're easier to kill if they are starving.
So DCA, polyMVA is a great combination to be able to do that.
PolyMVA is beautiful because it also works on the mitochondria
of the cell and with cancer cells you know,
we know that the mitochondria is quite dysfunctional
and that is why the cancer cell is shifting its energy production
into another alternate way which is a fermentation type
of way of creating energy.
So the DCA blocks that you know, fermentation component
and then polyMVA will then push the mitochondria
in its ability to produce energy
and the mitochondria, the beauty there is that it holds the key
to the cell death switch.
So when the mitochondria is functioning better
then the body is able to regulate better
into kind of recognizing if this cell is too dysfunctional
than to you know, cause that cell to die
or if it's not dysfunctional enough
the mitochondria will then help to repair the genetic,
the DNA so that we will shift away from oncogenes
or cancer causing genes to more normal and healthy
and kind of regular healthy cells.
So that's just kind of one and then we do curcumin IV
which is fantastic also in shutting down
about 200 different cancer drivers.
It if that was a pharmaceutical drug
it would be worth you know, many, many billions
but here we have it just natural.
We can take it orally and then you know,
when you do it IV-wise and the beauty there
is that you get it directly into the bloodstream
it gets into the cells and it just kind of base those
cancer cells and shuts down all the kind
of tumor necrosis factor B and if capa B
and Vege F and all these different drivers
that the cancer rely on in order to be able
to promote its own existence.
Do you then said people hold with like
polyambia orally, forgive it or do you
should put a protocol together for them
after they're there for two weeks?
Yeah, so all of this is then supported by diet
and also a supplement program
and I do also use you know, certain repurposed drugs
kind of like Jane McLelland, you know,
how to start cancer where you can use things
like low dose on track zone, hypermectin,
thin bandazole or men bandazole and then you know
also sometimes you have that the cancer
can have a very fungal component like Doug Kaufman
talks a lot about, you know, the fungal correlation
with cancer and that it looks very similar
to kind of fungal buds and its behaviors
are very similar.
So there's a strong correlation that
you know, we want to lean on also making sure
that there's a kind of fungal aspect over and above
that it can be, you know, so you can be
fine this or a tumor.
Yeah, so we want to kind of address
all those different things and so you have
oral supplementations, repurposed drugs, diet
and then obviously lifestyle habits
that we really want to lean into as well.
Do you have, in your clinic, do you have an option
where people can do more telemedicine?
Is that an option as well?
Absolutely and that is usually where things start.
You know, and so I have people, you know,
doing telemedicine from, you know, from all over,
you know, like I know you do.
And so this way I can then interact with them
and if they feel that there's a need for them
to come to the center for more intensive therapies,
they can do that.
But if we can then manage things
from afar, then we can do that as well.
And I can guide them in diet and supplementation
and then if they have then a local doctor
that's willing to prescribe some of the repurposed drugs
and we can work hand in hand with them
or they can come them to the center for a period
and we can then kind of prescribe it there
and then get some of the therapies here.
Now I just love your philosophy of care.
I think we think very much alike.
You add pieces that I can't legally add.
It's just complimentary, you know,
it's just fantastic what you do.
Anything new that you see in the horizon in your mind
and what you're wanting to add to your place
and anything that you see cutting down the pike
for alternative cancer?
Yeah, so one of the things that we are starting to look at,
we've done a lot of what's called platelet derived
non-aparticle delivery of agents.
So what that means is that we use the patient's own platelets,
we mix those platelets through a ultrasonic process
with specific agents that we want to get into the tumor site
and then we do a micro filtration of that
to make those particles very small, very non-anized
so that they can easily penetrate any kind of tissue.
And the beauty with platelets is that they tumors use platelets
for their own benefit and they are drawn to locations
of inflammation.
Obviously the cancer tumor micro environment
is very inflammatory.
So it becomes a very powerful delivery system
than of whatever agent that you want to get in there,
whether you're using mistletoe or artisanate
or whether you want to bring in some peptides
like times an alpha-1 to modulate that micro environment
or whether you want to kind of do a photosensitizer
to increase the concentration like methylene blue
or ICG or riboflavin which are powerful photosensitizer.
So that is what we've been doing for quite some time.
The next step we want to go is that if we have some people
that are really wanting chemotherapy or wanting some
but they don't want that big dose
and want a smaller dose of that
to just use a little bit of something like doxia ribusin
and then to have that the delivery system of these
and non-anice particles of the persons of patients platelets
to be able to then get the doxia ribusin into the location
of the tumor environment instead of it
then floating all over the place
and that way you can use a much less dose
and then also you can get it much more targeting.
So it's similar to IPT
but I think it will take that to the next level.
So we're kind of looking into that as a next step.
Well, it's fantastic.
You know, I'm excited about everything that you do.
I'm always intrigued when I talk to you
and I learned something new
and it just motivates me to keep moving forward.
So thank you for bringing your wealth of knowledge
to our patients.
Anything else you'd like to share?
I mean, we have all these amazing therapies
but the key is to really understand
kind of what are some of the underlying factors
of what cost the cancer in the first place.
So you do in addition to then obviously going after the tumor
going after the cancer process,
you want to look at the root costs
and that is where I know you do beautifully yourself.
And so that's when you want to look and see
what is driving this cancer?
What is the fuel for that?
Is it an emotional factor?
Is it chemicals, heavy metals?
Is it pathogens?
Talk a little bit about fungus.
What is it that's underneath that?
And so you cannot miss that aspect
in addition to going after the cancer process in itself.
So you want to have this multi-layered program
and that is why we do things like APNs
called the Plyte Psychonorebiology
where we use a muscle testing technique
to pinpoint and see where traumas are stored
and see where they're coming from.
And then also you can then correlate that.
So you have a whole meopathic bile of the cancer
like if you deal with prostate cancer,
we'll have a little vial of that.
And then you can then see which emotions,
which traumas where they're coming from.
It may not even be in this life.
It may be your parents life or grandparents
it may have been a generational component
that you have been helping to carry over time.
So then you can pinpoint that
and then use different techniques
to help to release that charge,
that trauma that's stored in the body.
And so that you don't have that as a gravitation point
for a tumor to form around.
So that is the key.
You want to kind of make your body not tumor-friendly
and working on traumas, emotions, toxins, pathogens,
eating well, it's our huge factors in that.
So that is just another aspect that we do.
Yeah, we talk to patients every day
that they're standard oncologists,
never cause, never even comes up in conversation.
I think the average person realizes
that that's really silly.
There was a reason that this happened.
And if you don't fix that reason
even though you might be able to zap the disease away,
it's going to come back in some way, shape, or form
and create another illness.
And you have to change the maloo.
You have to change the tumor surrounding the body
that created in the first place.
So I love that piece about what you do.
Lot of alternative doctors kind of ignore that piece too.
So I think we get so excited.
And just that we use natural agents sometimes
like a medical doctor use their pharmaceutical drugs
is that this disease, that pill,
and instead of looking at the individual as a whole
and recognizing what is it that is underneath,
instead of just, well, I have person has depression
where here's St. John's work or here's 5-HDP.
Instead, we need to kind of look at the whole
and understand what is causing that depression.
And obviously, we can look at the emotional,
but it could be gut dysbiosis or it could be toxic substances
that they're exposed to, an inflammatory process
that's triggered by something.
And so that's why it's important to not just kind of think
that here's a pill for this,
but then to really understand what's going on
with the individual to be able to address it fully
so that we're just not masking things
even just with natural agents.
Right, the disease, the dysfunction is really just
the manifestation of something deeper.
You know, we have to get to that something deeper.
Yeah, when people come here, I mean, they're busy
pretty much from 8-30 till 5 o'clock
and there's just therapy after therapy, you know,
colonics, ionic footbat, we do hockey,
we have flow presso working on the lymphatic,
we have sombal therapy, we have prayers for healing,
we have all the different IVs,
you know, obviously the photodynamic we've talked about.
Yeah, it's just a lot and we also, you know,
the ultrasound and the, yeah, it's scar therapies,
you know, neural therapy.
Yeah, we, it's a lot that happens when people come.
Yeah, that's what people need.
They need that intense approach sometimes.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And I want the listeners also to know that there is a,
a summit that's coming up and I know that we're,
we have you on that summit, that's going to be some of the,
the leaders in the world in regards to integrative oncology.
And I mean, the lineup is just phenomenal
of the speakers that are, that are going to be on it.
So for anyone that has any concern in regards to cancer,
then the, the summit that airs,
it starts airing October 31st
and it airs for free for a whole week.
So all the listeners, they can join for free.
Obviously, if you like the material and you want to revisit it,
you can purchase it for, for a very, you know,
small amount of money, but it's, it's going to be an incredible event.
And it's going to be some groundbreaking information.
Yeah, we have, you know, like, like yourself,
you know, Dr. Neil McKinney, Dr. Tony Hibbiness,
Dr. Paul Anderson, Dr. Thomas Seafrid.
You can, you know, people can look at the lineup
and I'm sure you'll provide a little link, you know,
that people can go to to kind of look at the lineup
that's going to be there.
Yeah, it's going to be an incredible summit.
And I'm, I'm really proud of it, then excited.
And it's going to be, you know, wonderful to share that information
with, with the audience.
Yes, that's another thing.
I like about you is that you just want to get information
out and help as many people as possible.
Yeah, and I think, you know, like, like yourself,
you know, the information is power.
And, and we don't want people to be powerless.
And that is what I see with people dealing with any kind of disease.
But, you know, cancer is just one that is,
is highlighted right now, is that if you,
if, if you don't take charge of your own health,
and if you don't become the driver of your own health,
you, you just kind of do like a somebody that, you know,
goes to the car mechanic and just drop off your car
and then pick it up after the weekend.
Yeah, we can't do that with our bodies.
You know, we shouldn't just kind of here take my body and fix it.
We need to be engaged and involved in, in our own healing process.
And with that education and knowledge, like, you know,
your podcasts that you're doing,
become so important so that we can then be involved
and, and, you know, and empower ourselves and empower our bodies,
you know, that God-given energy that, that we have and use that
to truly heal and, and behold, individuals.
Amen to that.
Yes.
100%.
Well, thank you so much.
And we're going to have links to your clinic and to your summit coming up.
So that's going to be very exciting to Dr. Carfield.
I thank you for your wisdom.
And all that you offer people just that God just continues to bless you
and your practice and your patience and that healing can ensue.
Thank you so much.
And you're such a blessing to the world, you know, with everything that that you do.
And it's an honor to know you and the honor to work along side with you
with, with people on their healing journey.
So thank you.
And I also want to let people know that in October, I am a relief.
I'm releasing my, my book is coming out.
It's a, it's a thick 450 page book about everything about cancer
and what you need to know to empower yourself.
So, you know, for all the listeners, keep an eye out for that as well.
Yes.
Looking forward to that.
We'll have links to that when that comes to you too.
Great.
Well, thank you so much, Dr. Carfields.
Always an honor.
All right.
Bye-bye.